[Musique]
on sait le bruit dérange les mammifères
marins qui vivent dans saint laurent
pour réduire l'impact de cette pollution
sonore les scientifiques ont installé au
milieu du fleuve une station des coudes
sous marine pour mesurer mieux que
jamais le bruit des navires
[Musique]
l'explorateur jacques yves cousteau
l'appelait le monde du silence
pourtant à y écouter de plus près force
est de constater que le monde sous marin
peut tous y est assourdissant
il peut en revanche qui a deux n'avait à
peu près en même temps dans tout système
saint laurent il faut pas oublier
l'accès près de 80% de tous nos biens
qui transitent par ce saint orens donc
on sait qu'il ya du bruit du bruit
généré par le trafic maritime qui
dérange les habitants des profondeurs
la pollution sonore sous marine peut
perturber les communications des manifs
air marin ou les déranger pendant qu'il
se nourrisse où se reproduisent
[Musique]
pour mieux comprendre l'origine de ces
bruits et trouver des solutions des
scientifiques de rimouski ont pris les
grands moyens
ils ont installé au beau milieu de la
voie navigable du saint-laurent un poste
des coudes sous marine une station de
recherche acoustique destinés à mesurer
dans les moindres détails les bruits
émis par les bateaux c'est unique il n'y
a pas d'autres citations comme ça dans
le monde et surtout pas à cette
profondeur là et dans une zone comme ça
dans laquelle aura autant de passages la
tâche des chercheurs va commencer sur la
terre ferme dans ce hangar de l'institut
maritime du québec
ont ce matin de juillet l'équipe de
charles massicotte met la touche finale
à ses équipements
quatre grands debout et bardé de
matériel scientifique
suspendu souche avoué trois hydrophones
comme celui ci vont enregistrer les
bruits sous marins
sur le dessus des antennes vont relayer
en temps réel les données recueillies
jusqu'à la côte via le réseau cellulaire
et entre chacun des éléments beaucoup
beaucoup de câbles
et en amis qu'on est dans un site
profond on a des licols qui vont être
très long pour relier tous nos
équipements on a environ 1500 mètres de
câbles par mouillage qui vont être
utilisés donc le défi ça va être que
tous ces câbles s'en mêle pop on encore
les déployer
la mise à l'eau a eu lieu au début de
l'été au large de rimouski une tâche
complexe et pas seulement à cause des
kilomètres de câbles
une fois plongé dans les eaux du fleuve
la position des hydrophones est cruciale
les quatre bouées forme deux portes
entre lesquels les navires ont circulé à
leur passage les hydrophones doit former
avec les bateaux des angles de 15 30 et
45 degrés pour que les données
recueillies soient conformes aux normes
internationales qui encadre ce type de
mesures
en matière de données de qualité la
profondeur du saint-laurent comporte un
avantage c'est ce qui nous permet
d'avoir les meilleures mesures
acoustiques c'est parce que quand on est
dans un endroit qui est peu profond
leçon va rebondir entre la surface et le
fond de l'eau ça va venir faire des
interférences fillon va se retrouver
avec des mesures qui vont être beaucoup
moins répétable le même bateau pourrait
passer deux fois qu'on aurait des
mesures très différents le fait d'avoir
quatre séries d'hydrophones et non une
seule permet de multiplier les données
sans obliger les navires à faire des
manoeuvres complexes un détour de
quelques minutes entre les deux couloirs
de navigation suffit à enregistrer leurs
émissions sonores c'était soit le but
d'avoir camouflage qui nous permettait
pas de mesures de chaque côté en un seul
passage
mesuré selon la norme pourquoi on fait
ça c'est parce que les bateaux
commerciaux il peut pas s'arrêter plus
faire plusieurs passage à le prendre et
une éternité et pour qu'il soit
intéressé à passer dans la station
fallait que ça est très peu d'impact sur
leurs opérations
la collaboration des armateurs ne se
limite pas à faire quelques détours en
plus d'écouter les navires sous l'eau
les chercheurs vont aussi à la source
nous voici à bord du bella dégâts ni qui
assure depuis rimouski le ravitaillement
de la côte-nord et commencerait presse
que ce serait possible de des communes
lesquelles génératrice successivement
qui devait partir la charge
dans la salle des machines l'équipe de
jean-christophe gauthier marc qui
installe ses instruments ce n'est pas le
bruit qui manque ici
l'endroit est tellement assourdissant
qu'il faut se parler par écrire
au milieu du vacarme les scientifiques
installés à des endroits stratégiques
ces petits capteurs des accéléromètres
ils vont mesurer les vibrations du
navire
ce rapace est caractérisé les sources de
bruit entend des rires donc typiquement
les sources de vue principalement par de
la machinerie donc génératrice d'un
système de propulsion les pompes et on
retire les caractériser donc voir torse
qui émettent comme ont vu les vibrations
et on regarde comment la structure réagi
à cette excitation qu'est ce qui va être
réellement rayonner l'ennui du maroc
vérifiez commencé son se répercute dans
l'eau l'équipe plonge en hydro phone le
long de la coque
quand on a une excitation à l'intérieur
du navire elle n'est pas directement
retransmise à nu maroc de certaines
fréquences qui vont être transmises
directement via d'autres moins
complètement atténuer donc le navire
agit parfois comme un filtre et on doit
caractériser ce titre là pour vraiment
comprendre qu'est-ce qui rayonne et noir
l'objectif ultime mesure et en même
temps le bruit à bord des navires et
dans l'eau via la station acoustique
pour identifier les sources sonores les
plus dérangeantes et chercher des moyens
d'y remédier
guillaume saintonge et un des
responsables du projet de station de
recherche acoustique marine
s'apprête au niveau de la maintenance de
certains des instruments sa peau et
isolé certains composants ça peut même
aller jusqu'à architecture donc revoir
une partie de l' architecture en
fonction de certains composants convoi
qui sont identifiés qui font du bruit
dans le bateau mais que se brûla se
transmet aussi sous l'eau
tout l'été les chercheurs ont rodé leurs
instruments puis commencer à recueillir
les premières données en novembre à bord
du navire de recherche coriolis 2
l'équipe de charme à scott était de
retour en mer pour récupérer son
équipement
le soleil à peine le vit
l'équipage est en place pour une mission
délicate faudra c'est d'anticiper
seloncourt il faut retrouver les
hydrophones intacte normalement tu as le
temps le voir on était vraiment
les chercheurs envoie d'abord sous l'eau
un signal accoustique pour relâcher
lancre qui retiennent matériel
[Musique]
toujours
les bonnes nouvelles le signal est
revenu l'encré larguer des hydrophones
remonte lentement des profondeurs
reste à scruter la mer à la recherche
des flotteurs qui les ramène à la
surface pour aller les chercher
il
en même temps que les centaines de
mètres de câbles encore une fois sans
qu'il s'en mêle aussi à bord le
professeur d'acoustique marine pierre
cauchy surveiller l'opération avec une
certaine appréhension
pendant qu'elle était dans l'eau les
antennes ont envoyé une partie leurs
données par le réseau cellulaire mais
une des quatre bouées n'a pas fonctionné
et sur les trois autres deux ont cessé
de transmettre au cours de l'automne
reste à voir si les cartes mémoires
contenues dans les idéaux phone ont
quand même enregistré le passage des
bateaux le travail de plusieurs
chercheurs et étudiants impliqués dans
le projet en dépend
et ben oui c enregistrés on l'a
on a 200 gigas de données heureusement
les enregistrements semblent intactes on
a eu des données de chaque passage de
navires donc on peut on a vraiment de
quoi
travailler tout l'hiver et on peut
produire des résultats déjà de cette
année donc ça c'est
un résultat très positif
à l'institut des sciences de la mer
pierre cauchy et ses collègues vont
passer les prochains mois à analyser ces
données
décortiquer les bruits des navires mais
aussi les chants de baleines le bruit du
vent bref tout ce qui fait le paysage
sonore du saint laurent chaque bande de
fréquence mois les sons graves en bas
les grosses baleines loi d' par là et
puis les sons plus aiguilles en eau et
plus la couleur et vivent plus le son
est fort donc là bas on voit on voit ya
un bateau qui passe une partie du
travail des chercheurs consiste à
nettoyer les enregistrements pour
obtenir le bruit propre de chaque navire
on aimerait bien enregistrer nos bateaux
dans un studio comme onfray pour des
voies où on sait fabriquer des murs qui
sont transparents ou le y aura aucun
écho on ne peut pas faire ça pour un
bateau de 300 m qui a besoin d'être dans
l'eau
donc on est obligé d'accepter qu'il va y
avoir des échos et d un effet lié à un
endroit où on est donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on doit corriger nous on
observe parce que il ya de l'écho là où
on enregistre mais on doit corriger ça
ils veulent ainsi recréer sa signature
acoustique une courbe qui montre la
puissance des différentes fréquences
émises par le bateau une sorte
d'empreinte sonore
la notion de signature acoustique et un
modèle idéal de bruit émis par le bateau
on voit que la forme de la courbe est
assez assez régulière et on à certains
endroits des pics et une fréquence où il
ya vraiment plus de bruit et ça va être
liés typiquement aux machines tournantes
qui est à bord qui ont tourné à faire
des bruits à rythme régulier donc c'est
là qu'on peut commencer à identifier
quelles sont les sources qui font du
bruit à bord du bateau
cette signature la va varier en fonction
du type de navire est ce que c'est un
gros bateau un petit bateau qui est-ce
qui transporte également fonction de
l'âge du navire potentiellement donc si
tous des liens qu'on va essayer
d'étudier puis de de mieux comprendre en
couplant ces courbes avec les données
recueillies à bord des navires les
chercheurs espèrent au cours des deux
prochaines années prévues au projet
identifié des sources de bruit
susceptibles d'être atténuées
pour que le monde sous-marin retrouve un
peu de son silence